>> THE NUMBER 2 EXECUTIVE AT
FACEBOOK SAID MISTAKES WERE MADE
AND THERE WILL BE CHANGES.
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY IS FACING A
PRIVACY SCANDAL THAT SPARKED
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE U.S. AND
SEVERAL OTHER COUNTRIES AND SENT
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER CHERYL
-- SHERYL SANDBERG ON AN
APOLOGY TOUR.
SHE JOINED DANA PERINO.
HOW DOES SANDBERG PLAN TO CALM
THE FEARS?
THEY RECOGNIZED THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM AND THEY WILL TRY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT.
THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT FACEBOOK HAS IS
ALMOST UNIMAGINABLE.
I ASKED HER ABOUT HOW BIG THE
COMPANY HAS GOTTEN.
>> IS FACEBOOK GETTING TOO BIG?
IT'S PART OF THE SUCCESS OF THE
BUSINESS.
2 BILLION USERS.
YOU CAN KEEP UP WITH THAT?
>> AT OUR SIZE AND SCOPE WE HAVE
REAL RESPONSIBILITY.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE HAVE THAT
QUESTION.
IT'S A QUESTION WE ARE
ANSWERING.
WE ARE RAMPING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
>> WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
SAY THEY HAVE GONE FROM 10,000
PEOPLE AND HIRING ANOTHER 20,000
PEOPLE TRYING TO DEAL WITH 2
BILLION USERS.
THAT SEEMS LIKE IT'S OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL.
THEY WILL BE ASKED ABOUT THAT
WHEN MARK ZUCKERBERG TESTIFIES
IN FRONT OF CONGRESS.
>> WHAT IS THE STRATEGY FOR
FACEBOOK GOING INTO THE HEARINGS
NEXT WEEK?
>> THIS WEEK THEY HAVE TRIED TO
SOFTEN THE GROUND.
THEY HAD POLICY ANNOUNCEMENTS
SHOWING THEY ARE TAKING ACTION.
TODAY RIGHT BEFORE THE SHOW.
AT 2 O'CLOCK.
THEY ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
POLITICAL ADS TO MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW WHERE THEY ARE COMING FROM
AND WHO IS FUNDING THEM.
IF THERE IS A PROBLEM YOU WILL
BE ALERTED AND THE PERSON WHO
PUT UP THE AD WILL BE ALERTED
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF
THE PROBLEM.
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO NEXT WEEKS
SHOW THAT FACEBOOK IS FOCUSSING
ON THE FUTURE.
WE KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
WON'T LET THEM DO THAT.
THEY WILL MAKE THEM PAY FOR THE
PROBLEMS OF THE PAST.
IT'S PART OF THE NECESSARY STEP.
YOU COULD ALSO SEE REGULATION
COMING OUT OF THIS.
IT WILL NOT ONLY AFFECT FACEBOOK